я це Вова Зеленський котрого я знаю він
у цій ситуації вчинив абсолютно
правильно добре гудбайки кричав і
Грайте з Україною москальні гарні
ти робиш клацання по носу е ось цим
цієї політики Путіна Та й вони
Забороняли російську мову, але чому ви
чекаєте від Ані Лора якихось там
якоїсь позиції чи ви зараз кажете
він може прилетіти Чому ви
виправдовуєте я не виправдовую просто
розумію
Андрій Данилко Ласкаво просимо до
Deutsche welle на програму
і я вам скажу Я навчався коли у школі
вчився я не читав що у мене був
німецька мова Я навіть з німцем
листувався Ну з хлопчиком клуб
Міжнародної дружби я дивився
сюди і Думаю Господи не ви повірити
дивіться почнемо ось заяви Алли
Пугачової з приводу того, що вона
протестує проти того, що Максим Галкін
оголошені агентом що вона сама інша
зачистили але агенти висловлювання щодо
з приводу війни в Україні і так далі
нічого не здивувало я знаю її добре та вона
людина дуже справедлива і щоб не
говорили там ці програми які
виходили на НТВ Яка мафіоз на цьому та
всі ці розповіді і я ж знаю її, а як
українця вас не Ну добре не образила То
що вона говорить про те, що
Ну давай треба закінчити те, що гинуть
наші хлопці незрозуміло за що Україну Вона
не сказала
але вона Росіянка вона сказала у своєму
народі вона переживає за свою країну
тому вона так сказала Не так абсолютно
Зрозуміло, наскільки
це може мати якийсь ефект ось на
громадська думка і так далі
коли кажуть ось мистецтво там
виховують
це розвага це
викликання якесь емоції Так але не треба
думати що це якось може людину
змінити не може це змінити Ну як я
думаю все ж тут дивіться і Путін же
дивився фільми там Білий Бім Чорне вухо
та й може бути і плакав багато це
якось вплинуло Ні він хвора людина
плюс злочинець це всім зрозуміло Ось ви
не виступали в Росії з тринадцятого
року уявімо що сьогодні
виступили перед російською аудиторією
десь ось як ви думаєте ви один одного
зрозуміли все-таки між артистом та
аудиторії є я вам скажу Ви знаєте хто
приходить до сердючки Тільки нормальні
люди тому що подібне
ось виступали у Вільнюсі була 70%
литовців
відчуваєш аудиторія багато було дуже
росіян і всі теж коли я кричав Путіна
була Вибачте, то всі раділи до
буде Щоб ти здох це такі Це я
придумав новий жанр такій образці і
там пишуть як це можна нашого
президента обзивати такими теж пишуть я
говорю так можна можна обзивати Я буду
обзивати Я не можу нічого зробити
іншого але це ось ці образи від
серця з приводу там Соловйова це
каструля Чому каструля ось у нас було
таке бідне дитинство та діти були дуже
як сказати
винахідлива не було санок ми брали
якийсь старий тазик
добре і ось каструлю прив'язували до
велосипеду їм цей каструлю
Ось це Соловйов Володимир соловей і ось
це каструля Я дуже хочу, щоб посадили
у в'язницю ось я просто мрію
Ось саме він розумний Подивіться 20 років
тому говорили про те, що ось багато
Україні нас надто багато впливу Росії
Я не знаю у літературі в кіно в серіалах
і так далі
зараз ну на передній край висунути в
українські артисти багато
у тому числі до речі серед російської
інтелігенції навіть критиків Путін
кажуть ось тепер Україна піде шляхом
такого кодового націоналізму означає
культурного ізоляціонізму ось хочуть
закрити музей Булгаков у Києві і так
далі тощо що це скажете
що відповісти дивіться все-таки ще було
Ось ця дія
Радянського Союзу ось
я нічого не бачив поганого в російській
музиці там чи в російських фільмах і те
що перейшли українською мовою це стало
більше це я вважаю що це добре ось
момент закриття музею Булгаків Мені
здається взагалі дуже дивна
якась історія не знаю я противник
цього і я не за те, щоб Забороняли
російська мова тим не менш Ну за цим за
речі своїми факт буде такою Це війна
вдарила по всьому, що пов'язано з Росією
Україні надовго десятиліття як мінімум
це буде викликати Дику огиду і
так далі зрозуміло чому
ось у цій ситуації Чи може щось
зробити ось людина культури артиста
сказати що війну не вийде
у багатьох хто повернеться
свою думку та думка абсолютно не
цікавить я вам скажу я дуже добрий
людина я за мир Я люблю об'єднувати
людей і ось ці люди які були на
концертах ось зараз і там чи будуть
багато приходять росіяни
Я дуже люблю об'єднувати це
єдиний момент
котрий я можу зробити на якийсь там
година щоб ми забули що ми посміхнулися
згадали якісь приємні моменти
Сердючка яка співає зараз пісні Ці
Расул гудбайки кричалки та яйця України
москальною гарною це не момент
плачемо так А мені теж ось це робиш
клацання по носу ось цим цієї політики
Путіна це я це роблю Ось із моментом
сили розумієте
сльози пошкодуєте нас Спасителя немає і вся
ця публіка була тисяч людей вони все
кричали
українською мовою
Розумієте мені важливий момент, вони бояться Але
той же Путін вони бояться сили Зеленський
Значить правильно супутнім надходить
Звичайно я Зеленський дуже добре я
кажу я не дивуюсь я це Вова
Зелений котрого я знаю він у цій
ситуації вчинив абсолютно правильно І
ця ситуація як би це не противно
звучала пішла йому на користь Розумієте
ось він тоді ось на самому початку він не
знав як поводитися якби я був я не
знав як поводитися це треба знати
якісь
все по-іншому він перестав хотіти
сподобатися
ось те що притаманний артисту лінощі дає
купку А колись написав книжку
називається Україна Чому Україна не
Росія Ось зараз як би Ви відповіли на
це питання Андрій Чому Україні Росії
Поясніть ось я раніше цього не помічав
тому що я Радянська дитина та Тоді для
мене столицю Москва і воно якось ось все
і відріжу Це від себе для мене
реально Москва це столиця ось я це все
Мені було дуже добре в Росії не
було цих митниць не було чудово.
не відчував у поїзді злочинців приїжджаючи
тоді мені здавалося ми немає ніякої
різниці але з часом це
дуже сильно чутно ми різні люди
навіть такий момент
українці вони
[музика]
ви стільки не б'єтеся Та але так
ось начебто ми можемо створювати
а у росіян найчастіше вкрасти
запозичити Чому немає зірки
міжнародної Та тому що все можна
знайти аналоги Так вони навіть імпорт це
заміщення і вони ж зробили серце теж
офіційно Сердючка є як вона
називається
чорти що вона називається вона ще співають
все буде жах якийсь балет начебто
залишки Надії Бабкіної у цьому стоїть
це такий Кошмар вони навіть це вони навіть
це знутд не можуть придумати свій
цікавить ось Ані Лорак Віра Брежнєва
Ось вони зробили собі кар'єру у Росії
Зараз вони загалом виявляються як
український
волонтером ось а їх Як ви вважаєте ось
українське суспільство
Я не знаю я до цього ставлюсь якось
інакше взагалі і я думаю не треба ось
до артистів та
Ну якось я не розумію чому така
реакція Я розумію, що це напевно
збирають аудиторію це дивляться Але чому
ви чекаєте від Ані Лора якихось там
якоїсь позиції чи це що
вам від цього Андрій Коли закінчиться
війна Привіт
Звідки знаю Давайте якщо хто ще не
знає ви навіть маску не знімаєте
що це правда мене весь час запитують
коли він з ними тату маску Я говорю Мені
набридло про це говорити коли я був у
цій масці я її Ну одягав тому що був
коронавірус і тому що я погано бачу і вона
весь час висіла мені тут якщо Я десь
клав на стіл Я не можу її знайти потім я
звик Мені здається зараз знімаю
наскільки наче сиджу голий вже ну я
сказав на початку війни я зніму маску
Коли закінчився
Ну ось я ось сказав я думаю що це
станеться дай Бог швидше темі артистів
Але з іншого боку До речі, ви умовний
там умовний Юрій Шевчук Котрий усю
життя співає на теми Ну яка дуже
сильно пов'язані з громадським життям там
свободою чечневою всі очікуються
нічого щось не змінить вплине коли
керівник театру там припустимо
театр нації Там Женя Миронов добре
ось якщо він скаже це вплине на нього
ситуацію Або добре чи погано і звичайно
тому він поїхав на Донбас я розумів
він заручник ситуацію він так не думав ви
зараз кажіть він може прилетіти
Чому ви виправдовуєте я неправду Я
просто розумію людина яка знаходиться
на такій посаді Так що має труп
який розуміє що за цим стоїть купа
людей гроші квартир Ось це дуже
складно те напевно в цьому випадку краще
промовчати
але я так розумію дуже багато
розмов йде зараз через війну через
того що це війна масштабна в Європі
не буде 80 років що ось період війни
Треба бути токсичним не можна сміятися або
там не можна чимось говорити краще
Чому якась придумана херня
Вибачте, чому не можна сміятися.
сміятися
в той момент, звичайно, ти вибираєш слова
звичайно ти не можеш дати якихось
оцінок І під час війни ти не можеш
говорити про якусь там дружбу
з росіянами там чи
з росіянами це не час для розмови
коли
ця війна закінчиться відбувається ось у
Україні День Перемоги ось яка у вас що
буде робити, але я з ним маску
нарешті-таки Так ми піднімемося на Білу
квартиру
Я кажу і будь ласка у Сільпо та і ми
звичайно відзначимо
я не можу ваш творчий план
Ви знаєте я це весь час перебуваючи у
Києві Я використав я собі такий
побудував графік я стільки зробив справ на
насправді там часто допомога там
переслали та
ненасичений день я почав ловити все на
думка Андрій ти ж перетворюється на
людини
Ось я наче цей Електроник знаєте
цей фільм Хлопці подивіться він плаче Я
думаю млинець Андрій ти перетворюєшся на
людину ти думаєш Блін у тебе ось
квартира є непоганий навіть ремонт
якось вони скажете вам скажуть люди
гинуть А він каже що він став війну
людиною
якщо питають люди як вас поміняла
війна запитує таке питання я говорю
ось мене ось Напевно у цьому плані
поміняв Я якось повернувся до себе я
Чому не хотів їздити на гастролі?
хочу бути порожнім Я не хочу ви сиділи
бачили як я вмираю Джулія Ламберг
вмирає на сцені
мені хочеться пожартувати не хочеться бути
легким вони видавлювати із себе жарти
Ні зараз мені легше зараз мені легше але
це не відповідає однаково як я
хочу
Я дуже вдячний публіці та квіти
приносять я вам скажу от якби не люди
мені б не було вже і як не намагалися там
ернсти ось ці доброчесності в цьому вся ця
гоп-компанії там нас знищити нічого
не вийшло останнє питання Ось ви
що хотіли б
у житті
я вам скажу мені хочеться бути здоровим
не хочеться щоб був
була можливість створювати якісь речі
мені не буде сім'ї це вже я розумію і
тому я вже не парюсь Ну от не дано
нічого страшного багато їсти знаєте як
за це Людмила прокопівна
службовому романі Що таке особисте життя
особисте життя багато інших цікавих
речей
робота Наприклад
я напевно це Людмила Прокоф'єва Але мені
би хотілося щоб усе було
насолода коли у мене є час
створення там програми номерів там
якісь пісеньки
на час на зйомки кліпу зробили поїхали
поділилися вони не бути знаєте як всі
час загнаний кінь ти весь час
викручуєшся ти весь час
підлаштовуєшся
обставини або
заплющуєш очі на непрофесійний
підхід інших людей
мені хотілося порядок
ось внутрішній порядок і мені хотілося
щоб було спокійно у мене картинка була
в голові ось я просто мрія я чомусь
Геленджик це мені дуже щось таке
смачне таке дуже тепле я там був з
мамою дев'ятого року
ось я пам'ятаю я сиджу на такому здоровенному
камені який такий теплий у мене була
улюблена байкова сорочка Байкова
хороша Я ось сиджу на цьому гарячому камені
захід сонця така ось така доріжка від
сонця так красиво я сиджу нікого не
відзначав і теплий камінь цей такий
приємний
хвилі ці Та якийсь птах пролетів
десь там корабель
Ось це мені щастя спокій
дивись Данилка Дякуємо за інтерв'ю з
Вами приємно Мені здається це якось
дурів трохи ні